[Musique]
strangers hills comment comment j'ai pu
passer à côté d'un tel chef-d'oeuvre
cette série est tout bonnement
incroyable et encore aujourd'hui je me
demande quelle est ma préférée entre
strangers things et game of thrones mais
bref là n'est pas le sujet la saison 3
de strangers things arrive durant l'été
2010 9 et des mystères sont à exploiter
néanmoins pour vous comme pour moi
résumons brièvement ce que nous savons
sur cette future saison
tout d'abord au niveau temporel la série
se passera durant l'été 1985 soit un an
après la saison 2 les enfants-acteurs
grandissent et arrive à l'adolescence il
faut s'adapter en fonction un événement
majeur arrive également le centre
commercial sur kaout le temps avance et
les centres commerciaux également
on n'arrête pas le progrès nous savons
que steve y travaillera et sera en
compagnie d'un tout nouveau personnage
du nom de maya qui seraient
potentiellement l'élément déclencheur
dévoilant encore une fois en moyen
d'accéder à l'aube side harnes
mais rien de sûr d'autres personnages
arriveront comme le maire d'auch keynes
ou une sauveteuse maître nageuse cette
saison sera également la plus poussée en
termes de moyens et d'effets spéciaux
ce qui semble promettre du lourd dr
bronner sera également de retour
l'acteur joue dans la saison 3 de
strangers things
mais est il réellement vivant où
jouera-t-il simplement des flashbacks
enfin oui il sera finalement mis au
repos pour cette saison ce dernier est
enfin débarrassé du mind flyers le
retour de cali alias ait n'est pas à
éviter non plus et pourra révéler
d'autres choses concernant les travaux
du laboratoire daou keynes voilà je
pense avoir résumé très succinctement
les points importants de la saison 3 je
pense qu'il est maintenant temps de
passer aux théories
[Musique]
comment sont très simplement avec
plusieurs suppositions que j'ai imaginé
comme vous le savez les frères de furs
les réalisateurs de la série s'inspire
de leur enfance et adolescence la saison
une tout comme la saison 2 mais
énormément en avant le jeu donjons et
dragons
au point que la réponse proviennent de
ce dernier les démos gorgon le mind
flyers toutes les réponses proviennent
de ce jeu la saison tourne également pas
mal autour du jeudi 2 go avec le réseau
de tunnels apportée par le mind flyer
est également ghosbusters avec la
matière organique
enfin on peut le supposer bref les
frères de furs s'inspirent de leur passé
pour écrire la série
si nous souhaitons nous projeter plus
loin il faut s'intéresser donc à l'année
1985 étant l'année de la saison 3 et
quel élément majeur de la pop culture
apparaît durant cette année
mario bros et retour vers le futur 2
oeuvres incontournables est encore très
connue à ce jour
ils ont été des cartons pour leur époque
du coup comment pourrait se tourner la
série en fonction de ses monuments
il est obligé que les frères de feurs
est été marqué par ses oeuvres
prenons tout d'abord mario bros la
princesse peach se fait kidnapper par
bowser et est enfermé dans son château
mario se doit d'aller la sauver en
parcourant le monde entier
bodeur pourrait être la métaphore du
mind flyers guidant ses troupes
les démons gorgon ou des mots dogues
pour empêcher le héros d'arriver à son
but
on peut les comparer à des combats ou
les koopas je vous laisse supposer par
vous même de qui pourrait être mario et
qui pourrait être pitch mais j'ai un peu
ma propre réponse à ce sujet le masne
flyers ou flagey leur mental est très en
colère suite à sa défaite face à heleven
ce dernier est toujours vivant et
n'attend qu'une chose revenir à hawkins
est justement ce dernier a été témoin
des actes d' eleven
là vu fermer le portail est donc le
vaincre théoriquement ce dernier a
aujourd'hui conscience de l'existence d'
eleven et ses pouvoirs le mind flyers
pourraient faire tout ce qui est
possible pour retrouver heleven et
l'emmener dans l'obs à y dorment que
l'on pourrait comparer au château de
bowser et la contrôler comme il l'avait
fait avec will et du coup contrôler ses
pouvoirs pour semer la zizanie
c'est une idée à garder en tête suite à
leur relation amoureuse on peut
facilement supposer que mike soit le
héros mario ou bien tout simplement
hooper ayant maintenant adopter la jeune
enfant une très forte la liaison les
rapproche d'ailleurs petite parenthèse
il est quasiment sûr à 100% que la
romance entre hopper et joyce bailleur
s'approfondissent bref enfin si nous
nous tournons vers retour vers le futur
le film ne racontait le retour dans le
passé de marty mcfly pour justement
sauver le docteur emmett brown d'une
mort prochaine soit une modification du
passé pour un présent et un futur
meilleur
donc la survie des met alors bien
évidemment tout ceci resterait dans le
cadre métaphorique concernant strangers
things à part si vous croyez dur comme
fer la théorie de l'ops down égale futur
apocalyptique de strangers x enfin voilà
la métaphore pour moi serait de chercher
à solutionner le problème de l'obs
haidar en retournant à ses origines pour
justement supprimer la source du
problème
encore présent on peut penser à comment
a été créé le braille down ou comment
est-il arrivé
ou tout simplement retourner au moment
où il a été ouvert et donc trouver une
solution par rapport à cet événement
ceci permettrait d'enfin avoir des
réponses sur le side harnes
potentiellement est aussi créés sont pas
graves
encore inconnu après deux saisons
plusieurs suppositions peuvent arriver
et ceci n'est qu'un avis personnel parmi
tant d'autres j'espère que ces premières
idées vous auront plus
[Musique]
le docteur martin trainer est pour moi
une clé scénaristique importante de la
saison 3 et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi
brender est celui qui a découvert
l'existence de l'obs aida une grâce ou à
cause tout dépend de votre point de vue
des expériences qui l'effectué sur
heleven et chose encore plus importante
il est celui qui a pris à heleven à
contrôler ses pouvoirs le docteur martin
brender est un personnage très central
de la série est très important la saison
une nous le présenter comme mort face au
démon gorgon
cependant la saison 2 nous montre
quelque chose de tout à fait différent
qu ali alias kate affirma heleven que
son papa est toujours vivant et qu'il
hante ses pensées et au moment où elle
retrouve un des employés fidèles du
docteur ce dernier leur jour que brender
est toujours en vie et qu'il peut les
conduire à lui bien que surréaliste
brender serait toujours en vie je pense
que vous connaissez aussi bien que moi
sur comment les séries fonctionnent
certains personnages disparaissent et
réapparaissent subitement cette mise en
scène où l'employé jure que son
employeur est toujours présent n'est
vraiment pas anodin et question
scénaristique ou cinéma si ceux ci a été
amenée est dit dans la série c'est que
c'est forcément vrai d'ailleurs nous
savons que brenner jouera dans la saison
3 comme je vous l'expliquais dans
l'introduction de la vidéo mais j'aimais
telle hypothèse qu'il ne s'agisse que de
flashbacks comme pour la saison 2
néanmoins tout ceci prouve entre
guillemets sa survie face aux démos
gorgon et l'acteur du docteur a
justement été assez mécontent de sa
disparition dans la saison une et
souhaite réellement faire son retour
eh bien ce sera chose faite je pense le
docteur est beaucoup trop importante
pour disparaître
je vous mentionnais justement le fait
que retour vers le futur était un carton
de l'année 1985 et bien brender en
serait la métaphore retourner aux
sources de la déco
art de l'opci down permettrait de
sûrement trouvé la solution à l'équation
et brenner et cette source
personne ne connaît mieux que lui le
zeit down où les pouvoirs des les fun si
on veut être un petit peu fou dans mon
argumentation on pourrait supposer que
le démon gorgon et put épargné la vie de
brenner étant celui à l'origine de la
découverte de l'obs haydn et de son
ouverture
pourquoi pas mais surtout on pourrait
retrouver un docteur déchiré par le
démon gorgon est totalement défigurée
ce grand acte de violence à son égard a
pu certainement lui faire prendre
conscience de la dangerosité de la zone
parallèle et pour est épaulé à sa façon
les habitants dawkins face à ce retour
imminent du man flyers d'ailleurs
qu'elle y sera forcément de retour dans
cette prochaine saison
scénaristiquement parlant c'est
impossible qu'un tel personnage apparaît
ce que dans un seul épisode et ne fasse
pas son retour et au vue de leur
inscription sur leurs bras il est
forcément obligé que d'autres enfants
ont fait l'objet de cobayes dans le
laboratoire dawkins personnellement et
je vais vous parler avec le coeur et mes
pensées
certains pourraient être morts et cali
et jane pourraient être les seules
survivantes ou bien une chasse à ces
autres cobayes serait une bonne
suppositions il pourrait être la clé
permettant de vaincre le mind flyers
mais ce serait plus pour la quatrième et
dernière saison de la série
enfin à part s'il reste sur l'idée d'une
potentielle cinquième saison et les
veines et pour moi l'expérience ultime
de brenner il n'y a pas plus puissant qu
elles d'après mon humble avis 11 serait
le nombre final des enfants cobayes on
peut même transcrire ces nombres par
rapport à une échelle de puissance et
les veines est beaucoup plus puissante
que cali en terme de pouvoir
c'est pour quoi elle porterait le
chiffre 8 et jane le nombre 11
mais au vu de la différence d'âge c'est
plus probable que c'est juste car elle
était cobayes avant jane bref en tout
cas cela veut donc dire que neuf autres
enfants sont encore en liberté
enfin
normalement le background de strangers
things a besoin d'être élargie pour
mieux comprendre l'ennemi d'où la
référence à retour vers le futur
brender pourrait rassembler la totalité
des enfants pour vaincre définitivement
le mind flyers ce retour aux sources
apporterait des réponses importantes et
je ne voulais pas spécifié mais la
saison 3 attendra beaucoup autour des
personnages et dans leur histoire normal
des réponses sur l'ancien vide hopper
n'est pas à négliger comme beaucoup le
spécule sarah aurait pu être l'objet
d'expériences dans le laboratoire
dawkins par le biais de parraineurs
sarah a peut être été le numéro 001 vu
que la mort de l'enfant était il ya
maintenant en main d'année le cancer de
la jeune fille était peut-être un
mensonge comme la fausse mort de will
pour cacher toute la vérité
les zones d'ombré sont de plus en plus
présente brenner et la zone d'ombré de
la série
pour cette dernière théorie j'aimerais
vous proposer une autre vision de voir
strangers things et qui risquent de
s'adapter aux futures de la série les
frères de furs les créateurs de la série
ont avoué que le my fire pourrait être
comparé à voldemort et donc à l'univers
d'harry potter
ces derniers veulent un méchant capable
de réfléchir d'agir avec des idées et
une conscience et non un simple monstre
fonctionnant avec de vulgaires instinct
d'animaux comme à requins comme dans la
saison 1 plus particulièrement avec le
démon gorgon qui s'animait que grâce à
des instincts primitifs c'est pourquoi
les frères de furs ont créé le mind
flyers pour la saison 2 en s'inspirant
de voldemort et du monde d'harry potter
alors oui la ressemblance n'est pas
flagrante du tout physiquement comme
mentalement mais nous aurons des
réponses
et justement le fait d'avouer que les
créateurs s'inspirent pas mal de
l'univers d'harry potter nous
permettrait de mieux comprendre le futur
de strangers things
si nous faisons quelques comparaisons
nous sommes dans une histoire où nous
suivons l'évolution d'un groupe
d'enfants qui vont grandir au fil du
temps et oui ces derniers seront déjà
des préadolescents dans la saison 3 tout
comme dans l'épopée d' harry ron et
hermione ensuite heleven est comme qui
dirait un petit peu la harry potter de
strangers things on le ressent depuis
pas mal d'épisodes heleven et comme
l'élu de strangers things possédant des
pouvoirs incroyables et confirmant
qu'elle est ou peut-être l'une des plus
puissantes des enfants victimes de
brûlures
cali n'est rien à côté des leeuwen
d'après ce que je pense en tout cas et
pour continuer dans cette vision parlons
de la liaison entre le mind flyers et
elven cette dernière est enfin connue
aux yeux de l'antagoniste la dernière
scène de strangers 6-2 nous montre
justement le masne fire surveillant les
enfants dont jane le mind flyers s'est
fait battre par et les voeux
et sa vengeance sera forcément dans la
saison 3 pour enrichir cette idée
l'histoire d'harry potter nous montre
les photos liaison entre l'élu et
voldemort mécary reste supérieur à ce
dernier grâce à l'amour entre guillemets
harry se bat pour protéger ceux qu'il
aime contrairement à voldemort qui est
dénoué de ce sentiment
le futur de strangers in remettra
forcément une confrontation ultime entre
le mind flyers et elven à l'heure
actuelle ces dernières se bat grâce à la
colère qui permet de décupler ses
pouvoirs mais nous sommes en présence
d'un groupe d'enfants évoluant
perpétuellement heleven tout comme les
autres va changer va évoluer et sera
plus puissantes au fil du temps j'ai une
comprendra certainement que se battre
pour protéger mike a beaucoup plus de
sens que d'utiliser la colère la saison
3 de strangers in ce qui apparemment se
tournerait pas mal autour des
personnages permettrait de nous montrer
cette évolution et cette construction du
personnage televen nous sommes encore
loin d'avoir des personnages d'une
grande maturité
chaque personnage de strangers things se
cherchent se construit l'exemple le plus
flagrant reste 96 et johnatan enfin bref
le background du mind flyers ainsi que
celui de loeb saïda où ou tout autre
personnage sera certainement développer
dans la saison 3 et je pense qu'elle
nous apportera énormément de réponses
après tout la série ferait quatre
saisons
[Musique]
strangers singh a vraiment été une
énorme surprise pour ma part possédant
netflix que depuis trois mois j'ai c'est
de découvrir de nouvelles oeuvres chaque
jour et soyez sûr que d'autres séries
passeront dans mon émission
je suis vraiment heureux d'avoir pu vous
parler de strangers in the et j'espère
que mes théories vous auront plus cette
série et je pense ma préférée aux côtés
de game of thrones je remercie ceux qui
laisseront un pouce bleus et qui
partageront la vidéo si vous souhaitez
me soutenir n'hésitez pas à regarder
quelques pubs sur youtube ça m'aide
grandement vous pouvez également me
suivre sur twitter c'est très important
eh bien écoutez cet argot rock et que le
lie à 9 heures soit avec vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]